[MUSIC PLAYING]
ANDREW PHILLIPS: Thank
you, everyone, for coming.
I see a few more
people showing up.
That's great.
My name's Andrew Phillips.
I'm a product manager
in GCP DevOps.
That's the part of
Google Cloud that
worries about local developer
and software delivery tooling.
And I want to be
kind of really quick
and efficient with my
part of this presentation
because I really want to
tee up John over there who's
going to introduce himself,
John Engelman from Target, who's
going to talk about a really
fascinating journey about
building, why, and how,
and lessons learned,
and application
delivery platform.
I'd like to kick it
off a little bit,
though, just by way
of introduction,
for setting the stage for
why it actually makes sense
to think about this
as a separate problem
in the first place, especially
in an enterprise context,
and some of the lessons that
we, from a Google perspective,
can share in that area.
We just said that, all right.
Blah, the me slide.
I mean, from a
background perspective,
I've been in this space
for a really long time.
I've been both a developer and
a head of duct tape, a.k.a.
head of operations,
and a project manager,
and all these kind of things.
So I've seen lots of pain from
lots of different angles here.
One of the things
I did a lot of when
I was a head of strategy
in this space was I
showed a slide like this.
Every enterprise must have seen
this slide 50 million times.
It's the classic
slide that says,
if you don't find
a way to speed up,
you are going to go bankrupt.
And there's lots of good
data to back this up.
And so it's a really
genuine problem.
And thus, I think
it's legitimate
that we all think about it.
But by and large,
people are convinced
that this is genuinely
an issue to look at.
And what then tends to
happen, and this is, I
think, where an important
lesson comes in,
is that you start drawing
a diagram like this, right?
Oh, my software
delivery pipeline.
Source code over here.
Got just a few
things I need to do,
and then I'm going
to be in production.
It kind of looks sort of
simple and compelling.
And you could
imagine if you have
a simple website with some code
that that could sort of work.
But of course, the
reality, first of all,
is that it's actually more
of a tooling landscape.
It looks a little bit like this.
And so it's an enormous
integration game
that you already
start to have to play.
And if you try to
play that integration
game all across the
pipeline in one go,
it's very quickly a boil
the ocean type problem.
And I think we all know
how this goes wrong.
And there's just too much
to tackle to get this right.
So I think an important
lesson to start out
with is that not just
there's a big challenge lying
under this deceptively
simple diagram.
But I think there's another
really important point.
And that is conceptually
thinking of it as this,
if I just go back one--
does this work?
Can I go back?
Thinking of it as this
conceptually simple left
to right, just do all the
things diagram obscures the fact
that there's actually two
related but different processes
at work here.
And so the way I
draw this diagram now
is a little bit more like this.
I don't really use
the term CI and CD
very much because
they kind of imply
automation and more automation.
Instead, I talk about
the developer feedback
cycle, and the
application release
cycle on the other side.
And I find that
framing helps me a lot
because, A, if you look
at what we do as Google
or what many other companies do,
your developer feedback cycle,
you want that to run every
single time you propose
or commit a code change.
And if any of you heard the
Cloud build announcement--
I'm sure a lot of you did--
Google's doing a
lot in this space
to provide great tooling to
make that really easy and really
efficient.
And this is all about
speed and efficiency,
and getting great information
back to your developers
as quickly as possible.
But then on the other side, you
have the application release
cycle, which maybe you
want to do every time
you commit a line of
code, or maybe not.
Maybe you do it weekly, or
every sprint, or whatever.
And here, there are
many different triggers.
And the goals are also
somewhat different.
You're typically not
worried all that much
about doing this as
fast as possible.
You're worried about doing
it in a compliant way,
in a way that prevents
risk from creating
problems for your organization,
et cetera, et cetera,
et cetera.
Safe, compliance, all these kind
of adjectives come into play.
And if I zoom in
a little bit more
specifically on that second half
of this pipeline, application
release, one of actually three
components from my perspective,
or from our perspective,
that are really
important to think about here.
Very often, if you think of it
as a pure automation problem,
you only really think
about the middle one,
application deployment,
which is those steps
that you need to take to get
your bits and bytes actually
into production.
But there's two other
very important parts
that we see a lot of people
recognizing at large scale.
One is the simple notion
of, how do I even understand
what is running where?
That's not a process problem.
That's a problem
of understanding
your current state.
And sure, if you have a
single runtime in a single GCP
project, that's not a big deal.
But if you're doing
multi-cluster,
multi-cloud, maybe different
types of run times,
it starts to become
a huge problem.
And not only do you want to
understand what's actually
out there, you
probably also want
to act on it in
certain limited ways.
You want to roll back.
You want to scale up.
You want to scale down.
You want to understand
health, and so on.
And then another aspect
of the deployment process
specifically, or the
application release process,
is that there's a bunch of
domain-specific best practices
that are really important
to implement in this area,
and that ideally you would like
tooling in this space to give
you out-of-the-box.
Whether it's things like
immutable infrastructure,
or good support for
rollbacks, or canary analysis,
or all these other kinds of
things, like everything else,
they can all be scripted.
But it's much,
much better if you
can provide this
functionality out of the box.
I'm not going to go
through all of them.
And then, obviously, from
a perspective of what
we know enterprises want,
and indeed, most developers
and operations teams want, great
to have all this functionality,
but we want it to be secure.
We ideally want it
to be open so it's
extensible and understandable.
We would like hybrid
and multi-cloud support.
And we want it to support
all the other 50,000
things you remember
from that slide I
showed a little earlier.
Because, of course, we can't
throw away everything we have.
We need to leverage our
existing investments, et cetera,
et cetera, et cetera.
So this is me teeing up
Spinnaker here, effectively.
This is an open-source
project which was originally
conceived-- well, the
predecessor version actually
was conceived as Netflix's
continuous delivery
platform for this part
of their life cycle.
And it's now a very successful
open-source project used by--
John will talk about how
Target uses it, but used
by Netflix, and Google, and
many, many other companies.
Obviously supports
all the runtimes
that we care about,
Kubernetes, big topic
here, but all the
other ones that we
know across multiple clouds.
And there's a lot
of people using it.
I won't bore you
with a logo slide.
It's a nice one
to look at later.
Going back to the four key
attributes that I talked about,
one of them was open.
And we find that very
important for our customers,
not just because that
gives them flexibility
in where and how
they run it, but also
because it gives companies'
release and platform
engineering teams the capability
to tailor it to their needs,
and to match the requirements
that every company comes up
against, and that is somewhat
different in their contexts.
So with that, let me
hand it over to John,
who will talk about exactly
how Target solved this problem.
JOHN ENGELMAN: Good
afternoon, everyone.
I'm very excited to
be up here talking
about Target's journey
on this path to today.
My name's John Engelman.
I'm a principal engineer
with the release and runtime
engineering group at Target.
And I basically do what Andrew
does as well, but for Target.
I'm also a regular
open-source contributor.
I've been working in kind
of the build automation
and deployment in cloud spaces
for a number of years now.
And prior to coming to Target,
I was working as a consultant
and doing this for everything
from 10-person companies
up to today where I'm
doing it for a Fortune 50
company in a number
of different spaces.
So before I get into how
Target does this today,
I want to give you a
little bit of idea,
and I want to reinforce
some of what Andrew
was saying just a little bit.
So first of all, from my
experience as a consultant,
this journey is not
unique to Target.
This is the same
path that I've seen
many, many companies go on.
I'm also not going to
stand here and tell you
the answer to this
problem, right,
because there isn't
one to answer.
I find that building
platforms, and
in particular this
application delivery space,
there's not a single solution
because the solutions have
to be geared for your
particular business
and technical
requirements, right?
It's almost a very personal
engineering problem
space to have happen.
Also, just simply, everything
Andrew said is right.
When we started putting
this talk together,
it was very interesting how
quickly our ideas coalesced
around the same things.
One of the issues that I
see in the industry right
now is that we have
a tendency to refer
to CI/CD as like a singular,
composite concept, right?
I have a CI/CD tool.
I'm doing CI/CD, et cetera.
But as Andrew was saying,
they are separate, right?
So continuous integration is
about modeling that software
development cycle,
how developers
are getting feedback.
How are we increasing
velocity and increasing
the quality of our code by
decreasing that cycle time?
And ultimately, the
outcome of that cycle
is that we're producing
a deployable artifact
that we consider good
based on the information
that we have today.
So one of the things
that we strive for
is to get this automated
code coverage that
covers everything.
And if anyone says that
they're aiming and striving
for 100% test coverage, that's
great, and we should do that,
but it's absolutely not
required to be successful
at continuous
integration, right?
And on the other side,
continuous deployment
is about that software
delivery cycle, right?
And here, the real purpose
is to decrease the impact
to customers of disruptive
operational actions
that we're taking on
our application, right?
And our outcome is
to make available
a new version of
our software and be
able to recover from any
possible regressions that
happened during that deployment.
So in this sense,
both of these actions
are orchestrated workflows,
but with very different
requirements, right?
And if you look at
it, a CI workflow
is very linear in
general, where,
if an error occurs
along that line,
we basically say stop, right?
Just stop, fail out,
don't do anything more.
And they're generally
very short running,
whereas in continuous
delivery, we
have this very complex
logic of what to do
when we're rolling out, right?
There's external forces
acting that are telling us
what to do next.
And, in a failure case, how
do we recover from that?
And these continuous
delivery workflows
can be very long-running,
anywhere from minutes
to hours to days or even
longer, depending on what type
of system we're rolling out.
So to summarize that,
CI and CD, really,
are two disparate ideas.
And it doesn't imply
that we're using
a single tool to solve them.
If you have a single tool that
solves both those problems
and it works for
you, that's great.
But we don't have to.
So, Target.
And how are we solving
some of these problems?
So before I tell you
what we're doing today
and what we're going
to be doing tomorrow,
I've got to tell you
where we came from
and what we were
doing yesterday.
So let's rewind the
clock five years.
So long before I joined Target--
and we were a traditional
enterprise organization, right?
We had development teams.
We had operations teams.
And developers built code,
and threw that over the wall
to operations teams that
deployed it and monitored
it and managed it, so a
very traditional workflow,
in that sense.
Our delivery cycles were tied
to business and financial
calendars, and all that stuff.
And I think any time that you
look at a state of a system
or a process or an
organization, there
are pros and cons to
both those things, right?
So one of the pros for this
kind of traditional enterprise,
even though most of us would say
there's nothing pro about it,
is that we did have de-coupled
development and delivery
cycles.
Now, it wasn't a
great decoupling
because we ended up in
these large, big bang
deliveries with intensive
integration cycles
and things like that.
And we also got into that
siloing of responsibilities,
right?
And when everyone thinks
someone else is responsible,
ultimately, no one ends
up being responsible.
And that's really coming
back to the TL;DR,
is just that we weren't
doing DevOps yet.
And this is a very
common starting point
for many, many enterprises
or large organizations.
So we knew we needed to change.
And our developers actually kind
of took that into their hand
and started to organically
grow the usage of Chef
as a configuration automation
tool within Target.
This allowed them to reliably
provision new servers
in a very consistent manner.
We were dropping our
times of how long it
took to get a server out there
and running very, very quickly,
from potentially weeks to hours.
So we started introducing
some commonality
through our processes.
We were able to write
some higher order
tests and functions.
We started sharing knowledge
among our development teams
about, what are the best
practices for really doing
this?
But on the other side, we went
from this de-coupled cycle
into now a process
where we were conflating
runtime configuration
with application versions
and application delivery.
We're obviously still using
mutable infrastructure,
so things like rollback
were very difficult.
And because it grew organically
and naturally out of dev teams,
there was no real
guidance, right?
So we started seeing some
anti-patterns developing
within the tooling and
implementation that we had.
So we knew we needed to
provide some structure
for our developers and users
to encode these best practices.
And one of those is that we
shouldn't use a configuration
management tool as a general
purpose orchestrator, right?
If we're just trying to
automate fluid tasks,
there's probably better tools
situated for that purpose.
And finally, we knew
we needed to model
the actual deployment
from the ground up,
and not just the runtime
of the application.
So after about a year of working
with Chef in the organization,
we started building a new
internal tool called Houston.
And Houston was an
infrastructure management tool.
So it was built around our
native infrastructure provider
APIs.
It used their tooling.
It still used Chef
underneath the hood
to provide runtime
configuration.
And again, it gave us a step to
more closely model and automate
more of what's needed to get
an application out and running.
And it further
reduced that time.
So we started introducing
concepts such as infrastructure
as code, deployment strategies
to our development teams.
We further reduced that time.
But on the other side, we
created a homegrown tool
that offered no support out
in the greater community.
When our devs had an
issue, they couldn't
go to Stack Overflow or
Google and find the answer
to the problem.
We couldn't source
any work or additions
to the tool from
outside of Target,
and not even from inside Target
because the code was so custom
that just the team that built
it was able to support it.
And the biggest mistake
that we made in Houston
was that we introduced our own
language to what an application
deployment was.
It had this idea of missions
and orbits and things like that.
And what we've
learned from that is
that we had built this tool
strictly from the vision
of, how are we going
to automate and make
infrastructure development
easier and better, right?
And that doesn't always
work for developers, right?
So we had this impedance
mismatch, right?
We had built a tool that was
really, really good managing
automated infrastructure,
but not so good at modeling
an application itself.
And we also learned
that we just shouldn't
try to create models
and abstractions that
don't convey what it is, right?
You have to talk about your
application deployments
in a way that is linked to the
practical concepts and features
that they represent, right?
So we don't call a dog
an orange because it's
a dog, not an orange, right?
So we should call
a server a server,
or an application
an application.
So after about,
again, another year
working with Houston, one of
our engineers came in and said,
hey, I've been playing around
with this tool out of Netflix
called Spinnaker
to do some things,
and I think it would help
solve a lot of problems for us.
And I'm not going to get into
all the deep down nitty-gritty
about Spinnaker.
There's lots of
resources out there.
But ultimately,
fundamentally, Spinnaker
is an immutable
infrastructure tool, right?
It's built around those
concepts of immutability.
And this was a very seismic
shift for our developers
and our infrastructure
to start thinking about.
We had to rethink many, many
parts of our platform, right?
We had to rethink how we were
getting runtime configuration
and Secrets.
We had to rethink how we
were packaging applications.
So we needed to start
small because there
were going to be a lot of moving
parts, and a lot of things
that we needed to
change and fix.
So we started with a small
pilot group of dev teams
that we knew could
move and make changes
as we found out and learned
lessons, and things like that
And as we started rolling
this out and working
with these pilot teams, we
learned a lot about Spinnaker,
right?
Because no one had the
experience with it yet.
But we knew that
Spinnaker's pipelines
were very robust at modeling how
we wanted to roll applications
out to places.
It gives you just about
anything you need out
of the box to do that.
But we didn't use all
of it all the time.
Most of our development
teams just simply
need to get an
application out, right?
It's a stateless application.
They need to bring up
a new server group,
they need to get
traffic to it, and they
need to shut down
the old one, right?
So while Spinnaker
has lots of ability
to model complex workflows,
we didn't necessarily
need it all out of the gate.
Where we did need it was to
support our infrastructure
teams, so things that weren't
stateless applications,
Elasticsearch, Kafka,
Cassandra, things
like this where we needed
much more refined control
in how we were deploying
large clusters of things.
And Spinnaker allowed
us to do that.
So not only did it solve
the simple problem for us,
it also allowed us to solve
the difficult problems as well.
So we did this pilot.
We were able to get better
visibility into our deployment
footprints.
We were getting
better consistency.
But our dev teams were
starting to tell us,
you're abstracting us too far
away from the infrastructure.
We want to be right on the
API, and things like that.
And the biggest
frustration that they
gave us is, it's three
years and you're giving us
a third platform, right?
So three years in a row,
we'd asked them to change.
So they were getting a little
bit frustrated on that.
So we had to stop and ask
ourselves, OK, do we do this?
Do we push this across
the whole organization?
Was there enough
value in doing it?
And unsurprisingly, yes.
If the answer to
this was no, it'd
be a very anti-climactic talk.
So if we look at the cost value
of what Spinnaker brought us
at the end was
this simplification
of the infrastructure.
So the primitives
that Spinnaker uses
to talk about applications, such
as server groups and clusters,
model any type of application
delivery really, really well.
And then on top of that, it
uses a naming base pattern
to correlate and
aggregate infrastructure
so that you get kind of an
application graph of what
belongs to an application.
It also has a really, really
good workflow orchestration
engine.
And if you've ever implemented
a workflow engine of any kind,
you know that they're hard.
So Spinnaker's engine,
it's very scalable.
It supports resuming
in error conditions,
or even restarts up it.
It's flexible.
It's fast.
And companies like
Google and Netflix
are using it to drive
giant deployments
across their organization,
so we know it's battle tested
and it works well.
And finally, if you heard our
CIO at the keynote yesterday
morning, Target wants to
support open-source communities
as much as possible.
We leverage a lot of
open-source technology,
and we want to
contribute back to that.
So Spinnaker, as
an open-source tool
with backings of many
companies, big and small,
was a great place for us
to get into that community.
So we could leverage their
knowledge, we could give back,
we could participate
in that whole thing.
So we've decided to move on
to a Spinnaker at this point.
And we have to figure out,
how do we move Spinnaker
out into the rest
of Target, right?
The first part is, we needed
to add support for Target's
private data centers.
So Spinnaker ships with a
number of cloud provider
implementations, but
not all of the ones
that we use in our
infrastructure were supported.
So we put together
a development team,
and we joined them up in
the Spinnaker community.
And they were highly active.
They collaborated
with some other teams,
and they started
contributing back
major implementations of
Spinnaker's underlying code
to support our infrastructure.
We also had to roll out
additional integration
with other platforms that
we have, such as Kubernetes
and things like that.
In order to facilitate
this internally,
we started organizing
flash builds
between development teams
and our platform engineers
to kind of sit with them
and be embedded with them
and move them onto
these platforms.
Because some of them
were moving from n
minus two platforms
from Chef into this,
and let alone from the previous
platform, from Houston.
So in the end, Target's
topology looks something
like this within our private
data center and public cloud.
We use OpenStack
for VM deployments.
We use Kubernetes
in our data center.
We use Google Cloud
Platform out on the edge.
We use other providers
on top of that as well.
So we're using quite a few
of the components inside
of Spinnaker at any given time.
And one of the things we
learned is, we probably
should have stopped
and rewound and thought
about how we were doing
things, because you
need to think about
how you're going
to be onboarding users and
applications into Spinnaker.
Because it's based
on this static name,
because it's based on
a naming convention,
and because you're dealing
with immutable infrastructure,
if you don't adhere to those
patterns right out of the gate,
you get into a
position where you're
having to move a lot of
things later in order
to make a better organization.
If you're looking at
running Spinnaker at scale,
you also need to understand
how Spinnaker's configuration
works, what the different
microservice components do,
and how you're going to
manage that configuration
and roll out changes
to your users.
Because if you're giving
your developers direct access
onto Spinnaker, you don't
want to be bringing it down
for them, right, because they
can't run their deployments
or manage their applications.
And finally, you
need to understand
exactly how the different
provider implementations
in Spinnaker that you're
going to be using actually
interface with those
downstream providers,
because this is going
to greatly impact
how you can scale and manage
performance of Spinnaker
itself.
So here's where we're
going to deviate
into kind of a quick expert
section of Spinnaker.
So I'll ask, is
anyone here running
Spinnaker at their companies?
All right, so some.
So scaling concerns as you
start bringing Spinnaker up.
If you're talking about
something like Target's scale,
not all provider
implementations in Spinnaker
are built the same.
So you can easily
run into problems
where, depending on
the implementation,
you could run into things
like API rate limit problems,
or even overloading the
downstream provider APIs.
So you want to
look at how you're
tuning some of those
polling intervals,
if you can do caching of
APIs and things like that.
The AWS implementation
and Spinnaker
has something called edda
that lets you cache API calls.
Also, make sure you have
enough memory to run things.
Because Spinnaker is collecting
data about your infrastructure,
it has to collect the current
state of all your deployments
before it can flush it into
its cache to do queries.
So you need to have that room to
get data as you're scaling out.
And finally, by
default, Spinnaker
uses Redis as a caching agent
for most of its components.
And Redis is single-threaded.
So at any time, only one thing
can be reading and writing
from Redis.
What you can do, though, is
make every Spinnaker component
use a different Redis instance.
And Redis instances are cheap.
Any cloud provider
you're going to be using
has managed Redis or
something compatible,
and just from day
one just deploy
a Redis instance
since for each thing.
Don't fall into the trap
of using a single Redis.
It also has some more
advanced concepts
where you can manage sharding
mechanisms inside of Spinnaker
itself by application
or origin or user
so that you can scale different
parts of the componentry.
So Spinnaker
deployment at Target
looks something like this.
There's a component
inside of Spinnaker
that's called Clouddriver
that's responsible for talking
to the downstream provider APIs.
And we run those in
both a read/write
and a read-only mode.
So we have one fleet
of Clouddrivers
that can make the
mutate operations
into our infrastructure.
And we have another
fleet that is just
purely responsible for
gathering the current state
of that infrastructure back.
Those Clouddriver
implementations
talk to fleets of
read/write Redis instances
that are replicating their
data to read-only instances
of Redis.
So we can manage that.
And in between the
two, we actually
run an open-source
application called
2N proxy that allows us to
shard data across multiple Redis
instances.
So we can kind of get that
feel of a multi-threaded Redis
instance even though
it's single-threaded.
And this whole thing is
automated and configured
in such a way that
if we even need
to bring up a whole new
Spinnaker installation in order
to support something, we
can do that at, effectively,
the press of a button.
So in the end, we ended up with
a typology, or an installation,
of Spinnaker that has multiple
scaling dimensions, right?
We can scale everywhere
from the cache up
to the individual Spinnaker
components, and then Spinnaker
installations themselves.
And we can adjust the right
knob for whatever performance
problem we're seeing, or if
we've just suddenly increased
load or scale on something.
And this ended up being a
really good process for us,
because we did run
into situations where,
before we had this
topology, we would
run into some type of
scale-induced thing,
and we wouldn't be able
to adjust correctly.
So that's where we are
in our private data
center and our public
cloud usage right now.
Most of our app teams are
using Spinnaker to deploy
to VM-based workloads.
Some of them are using
Spinnaker to deploy
to Kubernetes-based workloads.
But we are starting to see
a little bit of a divergence
here where a lot of app
teams just want to--
if they're on
Kubernetes, they just
want to talk Kubernetes, right?
They want to use kubectl.
They want to use Helm.
They want to go straight
to that cluster,
and they want to use native
communities capabilities
across there.
So we've gotten a bit of a
divergence there happening.
And as we talk about
Kubernetes, I'd
be remiss if I didn't
talk about Target stores.
So not only do we have private
data center and public cloud,
but Target has 1,800 stores
across the United States.
And in each one of these stores
and distribution centers,
we run a Kubernetes cluster.
But because of the
distribution of these stores
and these distribution centers,
and the connectivity that we
have with them, we
have to treat them
as though they're completely
isolated cloud environments
from our perspective.
We can't be back
hauling data from them
all the way back to Minneapolis
all the time, right?
So effectively, we have
1,800 cloud providers
that we have to deal
with at any given time.
So how do we manage this?
How do we manage
rolling software out
to 1,800 disparate clouds?
So the first thing that we do
is we group our stores into kind
of groupings and environments
based on things like geography,
or size of the
store, or features,
or technology that we
have installed in them,
and things like that.
So these environments
can consist of anywhere
from one store to 300 stores.
And when we push new software
loads out to the stores,
we roll them out to
these environments
in a sort of batch
type fashion, right?
So if I push to an environment
that has 50 stores in it,
all 50 stores are going to
get that same software load
and be running it.
If I'm going to roll that
back, all 50 of those stores
roll back that software.
So how does Spinnaker
understand this kind
of weird grouping
thing that we're
doing with all these stores?
You probably haven't read the
Target blog, but if you had,
we recently posted a thing,
and it's called Unimatrix.
So Unimatrix is a tool
that we built in-house
to manage our store deployments.
And it effectively is a
Kubernetes API facade layer.
So it presents a
Kubernetes-compliant API,
ReplicaSets, and Pods services,
ConfigMaps, the whole spiel,
and it presents those store
groupings as name spaces
onto that API.
So we point our
Spinnaker instance
at the Unimatrix server
running in our data center,
and it distributes
desired state out
to each of the stores
in that namespace.
And the Unimatrix agent
there then applies that state
to the local Kubernetes
cluster, and is
responsible for recovering
status and sending it back
to us.
So from Spinnaker's
point of view,
we have one Kubernetes cluster
running for all 1,800 stores.
And this allows us to reason
about very large scale
deployments in
very simple terms,
for both our developers and any
operations and support staff
that we have to deal with.
It helps us eliminate deployment
drift across these store
environments.
And we're adhering and utilizing
open-source API specification,
which means any of the
tooling out there that's
built against Kubernetes
API we can continue
to use against our
store deployments,
even though we have 1,800
of them behind the scenes.
So what have we learned
from running Unimatrix?
We've been running
this for a while
now in our store
deployments, and we've
learned that abstracting the
infrastructure is good, right?
It allows us to
reduce that complexity
and make better decisions
about what should be done.
That doesn't mean our developers
shouldn't interact directly
with that API.
Many of our stores'
developers still
use kubectl to talk to Unimatrix
in order to perform operations
in the stores' environments.
We also needed to start
thinking about, well,
what really is an application
or deployment, right?
And so Unimatrix helps
us distill those concepts
down to what should
be running, how is it
configured, what's its current
state, things like that.
And it also kind of taught us
that this microservice thing
is really, really good
because we can just
replace pieces of
componentry where we see fit
with our opinions or patterns or
optimizations that work for us.
So that's our current
state today at Target.
And about six months
ago, we started
working on a new project
because our current state
is one where we still have many
different ways of doing things,
right?
We're still talking to some
Kubernetes clusters directly.
We're using Spinnaker in places.
We're using Unimatrix for
stores, et cetera, right?
And we really want to
get to this paradigm of,
there should just be one
way of writing and running
and deploying an
application at Target.
And the way that
we think about it
is the idea of a
midnight developer.
And Dan Woods, our distinguished
engineer, had a good point,
had a really good
statement of this,
says a developer
at Target has to be
able to build an application
in the middle of the night
without having to
interact with anyone,
with no previous
knowledge of our platform.
If they can't do that, then
we've failed as an engineering
and as a platform
organization, right?
And so, that's really
kind of the guidance
of what we've been trying to
do over the last six months.
And so there's kind of six main
points of how we're designing
and building that platform.
So first, we have to have a
self-service platform, right?
Our developers can't be sending
emails or issuing pull requests
or doing things and waiting
for people to get back
to them a day later.
We have to have a common
pattern of usability, right?
Regardless of where they're
running on the infrastructure,
they need be able to write
that application one time.
They need to be able to discover
the features of that platform.
It needs to be highly available
so that they can do their job.
And the way that we
can do that is through
applying some strong
opinions but still
allowing for flexibility
within the infrastructure
and the platform itself.
And finally, as
platform engineers,
we need to treat everything
as an application.
If we're going to be asking
our developers to follow
these processes or
use these opinions
or run on this platform,
then we better be, too.
So over the last
six months, we've
been building a new platform
called Target Application
Platform, or TAP.
And it's combining
the best pieces
of all the different
tools and all
the different
infrastructures that we've
dealt with over
the last five years
as we've come along
on this journey.
We're combining the power of
Kubernetes' declarative API
along with Spinnaker's
imperative workflow
engine to orchestrate
deployments
so that we can manage
our infrastructure
as a ubiquitous experience
for our developers, right?
And so, as part of that,
we're moving our developers
up the stack.
We're getting them up off
of those infrastructure
APIs so that our infrastructure
teams can innovate and move
fast and do the things that
they need to do in order
to make the
infrastructure better
without impacting the
application developers.
I recently had a meeting with
one of our big development
groups, and the director
there was explaining
that his team is now accounting
in actual number of what
they referred to as the
tech tax on their team.
And this tech tax is
the time that they're
losing building business
value because infrastructure
teams keep coming
and asking them
to migrate or do new things by
XYZ date for ABC reason, right?
And that's really what we
want to get rid of, right?
We need to stop doing that as
an infrastructure organization,
or as platform developers.
We need to allow app developers
to focus on building business
value and stop worrying
about the infrastructure.
So we want to reduce
that cognitive load, that
write once, run anywhere.
I shouldn't have to change
my application in order
to move it from a
container-based runtime
to a VM-based runtime.
I need to make sure that
my workloads are deploying
consistently regardless of where
they are in the infrastructure.
And I need my
infrastructure teams
to be able to do
their job by upgrading
clusters or innovating
new technologies,
and building things
that can span
across the entire enterprise.
So in order to
support this, we've
decided to take what we
learned from Unimatrix
and extend it to all of
Target's infrastructure.
So we settled on saying all
infrastructure at Target, when
it comes to runtime deployments
or workload deployment
and running, has to be managed
via the Kubernetes API.
So we talk about
all workloads on TAP
as though they're a ReplicaSet
and a Pod, regardless
of if it's on a Kubernetes
cluster or not, right?
So we write layers
that interface
with things like
OpenStack, and then
present a Kubernetes-compliant
API on top of it.
This gives us a single,
unified experience
across all of our
infrastructure.
It also allows us
then to deploy a type
of intelligent routing layer
on top of that infrastructure
that Spinnaker talks
to to do deployments.
Now, that routing layer,
that intelligence engine,
can consume data from wherever
we want it to in order
to make workload
placement decisions
about your application.
It also allows us to
do things like, if we
want to upgrade a Kubernetes
cluster that requires
an outage, we can just bring
up a new Kubernetes cluster,
disable the old one.
The existing workloads
will continue running,
and all new deployments will
go to the new cluster, right?
So in order to make
this work, and if we're
going to use the
Kubernetes API everywhere,
we have to model
a concept of what
an application is so
that it works across all
of these things, right?
So we have to talk about
what we're going to deploy.
And since it's
Kubernetes, we're going
to be deploying
Docker containers.
So application developers
at Target on TAP,
during their CI process, build
and publish a Docker container.
And that's the end of the story.
They'll never have
to change that.
They'll never have to
do anything different.
They just need to tell us how
much CPU and memory they want.
They need to tell us
what network port they're
going to accept traffic on.
They need to tell us, how do
they want their application
to roll out, right?
What should we do
with the old version?
How many Replicas should we run?
And finally, they
need to tell us,
how do we know that
your application is
healthy at any
given time, right?
Those are fundamentally the
core concepts of an application.
So if everything's
a Docker container
and that's what our
developers are building,
how do we do things
like run on OpenStack?
Well, our layer that sits
in front of OpenStack then,
when it receives a deployment
command as a ReplicaSet,
can call out to our enterprise
bakery, which is actually
one of the subcomponents
of Spinnaker
that we've just extracted
and are running standalone
without the rest of Spinnaker.
And so we do a just-in-time bake
of a VM image of that Docker
container.
So we translate that Docker
container into a VM deployment,
and then tell OpenStack
to go run that.
So we're able to use all of
Spinnaker's built-in abilities
for modeling
container-based deployments.
We can use triggering, and
we can do all the stuff
that we want to do.
But we can extend it
across any infrastructure
that we want to bring in.
And tomorrow, when one
of my developers says,
hey, we want to use
Nomad or something,
we can plug Nomad into this
system with very little effort
and not impact our
application developers.
So we could start testing
workload deployments on there
if we wanted to.
We also have to provide
a consistent set
of runtime primitives to
our applications, right?
If we were running on Kubernetes
and our developers were using
ConfigMaps and
Secrets and services
and all that stuff
via a cluster,
they'd be locked into
the Kubernetes ecosystem,
and they wouldn't be able to run
on something like an OpenStack
if they needed to.
So we couldn't do that.
So we run all of those
primitives outside
of the cluster-based workloads
with things like HashiCorp
Consul and Vault.
We use a global Fabio load
balancing layer for this.
And all of our workloads
that are deployed,
regardless of where it
is in the infrastructure,
gets a routable IP
address for this sake.
So we're not doing
any network overlay.
We also provide primitives
for logs and metrics,
and kind of API
proxying things so
that we can reason
about applications
in a very consistent manner.
And this allows us
to do kind of SRE
and support operations across
all the applications on TAP
very readily without
having to know specifics
about that application.
And finally, I
mentioned before, when
we started playing
with Spinnaker,
we noticed that a
lot of our developers
don't use all the capabilities
of a complex pipeline
of any kind.
And since we've distilled
this model of what
an application or
a deployment is
down to these kind
of core concepts,
we can also encode
a best practice
of how we're going to
roll out an application
into our infrastructure.
And we can do that
synthetically in a way
that Spinnaker doesn't
need to know the fully
materialized pipeline.
We can generate
it for them based
on what they're telling
us about the application.
So we've written
a new application
that exists as part of our
Spinnaker installation.
Spinnaker has a
component called Front50.
It's responsible for storing
your pipeline metadata.
So we wrote an
application called Back40,
and it synthetically
generates pipeline information
based on application metadata.
It also allows us
to, if we need to,
inject in a fully materialized
pipeline for Spinnaker.
So if we need to build some
type of complex workflow,
we can do that, right?
And this allows us
to kind of manage
best practices for deployments
across the whole enterprise
without having to
go to developers
and ask them to, hey, go
modify these pipelines.
So that is kind of the
Target of the future of where
we're going, right?
And it's been a long
journey to get there, right,
long in a sense.
But in the last
five years, we've
tried a lot of
different things, right?
We've experimented with a
lot of tools and patterns.
We've learned a lot about
what our developers want to do
and what they really need to do.
And we've fine-tuned we treat as
an application or a deployment
or workload at Target
so that we can reason
about the scale a lot easier.
So before I go, just my final
thoughts on all of this.
If you're not doing
immutable infrastructure yet,
you should probably start.
It gives you a real
solid foundation
for building consistent
deployment and operations
patterns for your organization.
And Spinnaker really will help
you drive that type of adoption
if you aren't doing it yet.
And it provides many
of the best practices
so you don't need to
create them yourself.
If you're building a
platform for yourself,
or if you're looking to
customize these tools,
don't be afraid to shape your
usage with flexible opinions.
Your developers are always
going to ask for all the things.
But managing scale
is a lot easier
when you have
opinionated patterns
of how your developers can
use those tools, right?
And Spinnaker will help you
model a lot of those cloud
providers in a consistent
set of primitives
and how we're going to
talk about an application
or how we're going to
talk about a deployment.
And finally, don't be
afraid to customize, right?
This is really the
power of why we
went from big,
conjoined applications
into microservices, right, that
are responsible for singular
things, right?
Using open-source tooling gives
you a lot of productivity,
but don't be afraid to
customize that tooling
for your specific needs, if
it makes sense to, right?
And in this case, Spinnaker's
design and architecture
will allow you to give you
a default installation out
of the box with
all the goodness.
But then you can piecemeal
things if you need to,
or take them and run them
completely on their own
in a standalone environment.
So I hope what I was
talking about today was
interesting to you.
I hope you have a great
rest of the conference,
and thank you very much.
[MUSIC PLAYING]